wow this movie must have had the
shortest script
[Music]
Ever So Silent nights directed by
legendary action filmmaker John Woo
Broken Arrow yes face off yes for me it
goes back to hardboiled on the laser
disc
baby what a weird Flex check out my old
Tech now let's talk about a movie where
no one talks moments like that make me
say thank you for sticking around this
long love you for that let's get to work
talking about a Movie for worry all
right so John wo directs this movie
about a guy who gets shot in the vocal
cords so he's on a Revenge Quest well
Revenge Quest because his son was shot
prior that's why he was chasing the
people down and shot his son may sound
weird why didn't I lead with that well
because the movie kind of didn't either
so yeah the stick when I saw it in the
trailer I was like oh that's kind of
cool he gets shot in the vocal cords he
can't talk but he's on his revenge Quest
but it doesn't stop there he doesn't
talk because he got shot in the vocal
cords everyone else and an apparent show
of solidarity well they don't talk
either it truly is silent night I mean
yeah there's some background chatter
some radio chatter but the characters in
the movie just don't talk since it's
John W let's start out with the action
all right before I start going in on the
things that bothered me the action was
fun it's ridiculous yes but John Woo
action's always been ridiculous but the
ridiculous element's a little different
it's always been yeah every gun has
unlimited ammo because John Wu ID KFA
all around no one ever has to reload now
it's the main protagonist is apparently
Fortune from Metal Gear Solid 2 and
bullets just miss I also like that this
guy was just an everyday man you know
he's just an everyday guy he a husband a
father he's not a cop he's not a marine
not an ex-marine he's not the Punisher
sometimes it feels like they borrowed
from The Punisher but he's not strictly
speaking The Punisher he learned how to
fight where 2023 Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles learned how to fight YouTube
baby he has to work out get in shape
learn some CQC learn how to shoot a gun
gun the year leading up to it we'll say
9 months after he goes through his
healing phase and then really Broody
drinking phase and he's like you know
what I'm going to kill some folk we'll
call it 9 months a solid school year
that time is training montage time he
truly does feel like someone who's never
touched a gun in his life and it goes
all the way up to yeah he can he can lay
some folks out granted in the ridiculous
John Woo way being able to hit paper is
different than being able to shoot
people while you're driving in a car and
it's just mid shots the whole time but
the bummer really comes from the fact
you don't know anything about anyone
else in this movie they all come across
as useless when they're really not
supposed to you know what you need to
know about the main dude he's a graving
father out for Revenge you seen it
before absolutely you have but it would
have been fine for him to be the one who
couldn't talk and everyone else maybe
they could you know they call him
cholesterol cholesterol he's coming for
us the silent killer again thank you for
sticking around for this long among all
my dad jokes like there's this cop dude
in this movie and he's kind of helping
him out in that way vigilante sometimes
do you know it's like I maybe I have an
ally on the force maybe he'll join in
later who knows but I don't know [__]
all about this guy so I really didn't
care I feel like this movie is a
conglomerate a Frank and [__] of other
Revenge movies stitched together but
they just took away all the vocals took
away the speech and that was different
like when he's doing recon taking photos
taking notes I was like like Thomas Jane
Punisher but Thomas Jane Punisher did it
better I feel like a lot of people hate
that movie I don't I don't give a [__]
it missed the Mark I started to fall
into it when I realized okay so not just
him everybody nobody talks in the movie
and that's kind of the thing here okay
let's fall into it but what you still
have is a barebones Revenge flick that
does have the unique premise of nobody
saying anything in the movie but
underneath that unique premise you have
elements that have been borrowed from
other Revenge movies and quite frankly
those other movies were more enjoyable
to sit through there some times I've
seen this in a lot of action movies
lately I'm like is that blood CGI there
are a couple of really good hits that
didn't look overly CGI it was actually
pretty badass and some blood spatter
that looks straight up CGI but you
couldn't have the little Detonator under
the shirt that goes boom shitty reality
television can have that your John Woo
action film can't these truly are dark
times this movie doesn't just lack
speech with emotional beats that fall
flat and characters you know nothing
about and don't care about in the least
what this movie Rel lack is
communication you can have emotional
moments with no speech profound moments
with no speech you kidding me we were
all there for the first 10 minutes of up
we wept all of us it's possible it can
happen just not in this movie couple of
coolish Parts aside it's a disappointing
film from a legendary director and I'm
not going to remember it in T minus one
day yep already forgot and I got a
review of Godzilla minus one dropping
tomorrow morning so be on the lookout
for that appreciate your patience for
that one all right so Silent Night have
you seen it what did you think about it
what's your favorite John Woo movie in
fact top three favorite John Woo movies
I don't know it's a little obscure
usually it's what's your favorite or
rank them we're going three no medals
for fourth place today whatever they are
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see
[Music]
more